[Musique]
vous n'êtes pas le premier à prétendre qu'ils ont
capturé une tour terroriste,
nous avons ceci
[Musique]
ah
vous êtes libre
ici
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique] faites
venir le prochain vendeur et transférez 10
000 unités à  ce dernier est le prochain arrêt
hé là je suis star-lord d'
accord drax le destroyer
la défaite du titan fou
dans la chair
et une
telle chair
[Musique]
ta présence m'honore
tu es beaucoup plus petit que ce à quoi je m'attendais
oh
et à quoi tu t'attendais
peut-être  je peux faire quelque chose à ce sujet
peu probable que
nous verrons destroyer
je peux être assez
énergique
peter quill
je crois qu'elle flirte avec moi
hellbender
je peux voir par la taille de votre arme que vous
devez être un guerrier habile
peut-être que je peux vous faire une démonstration
parfois
vous feriez un adversaire acceptable
dites-moi
destroyer
ce qui vous amène au deuxième des neuf
hé là salut euh
je suis star-lord
Drax est  en fait, avec moi, le chef
des gardiens de la galaxie a peut-être
entendu parler de nous,
non,
eh bien, laissez-moi vous dire
maintenant que vous avez de la
chance.
[Musique]
vous